[Musica]
[Risate]
26 ma oggi i nuovissimi scritto del
gruppo scappare dalla scuola piena di
soldi quindi dobbiamo scappare dagli
intoppi brace un mi piace passato
entrambi in queste cose se non vuoi
anche tu essere inseguito dal nome 54
abete tiri comodi prenderti il corno
iniziamo a teheran ha noi
eccoci qua io ho le ali da fatina
nuovamente quante volte si è sfracellato
e stavolta vitale leso è sfracellato nel
pavimento
la scuola è infestato dagli zombie
dobbiamo scappare da qui ok guarda
alcune zone sono pa per fortuna ci sono
le grandi stanno perdendo la slia qual è
la fama di zombie anche quasi un po di
base di zombie
ecco primo sfracella mente un'idea di
cosa stia succedendo cosa sia successo
qua
cosa successa ci sono delle matite
musicali o no come gigante ma vedete
anche voi questa parte blu quando
cancellate con la parte di blu della
gomma per settembre la festa poi gli si
strappa tutto il foglio sinistro visto
il capo della grata la ventola abbiamo
aspettato finito e cosa no mai asa st
vitale subentrato il pavimento della
boxe attento dice di premere questo
bottone si fidiamo non ci stiamo
[Musica]
sembra che siamo stati tale
teletrasportati in un'altra dimensione
ma c'è del cibo qui non ci credo questo
bottone era apposta per evitare bene ma
non prendere grosso non prendere il
nostro momento nel quale vado proviamo
artigiani nel giallo di una tecnica per
queste cose le lascio andare avanti gli
altri giocatori ma è la fontana di
cioccolato o devi stare attenta quando
salto e quello stesso mattonella al
momento che la vita le star in un sacco
di fame piano piano vai piano è arrivata
dai mi aspetto che ecco ti guarda la
cella stop ostaggio per il portale
prima di tornare dove eravamo prima via
scappiamo scappiamo anche se vorrebbe
rimanere ma non siamo tornati dove
eravamo prima stiamo a scuola slava si
movimenterà va guardato dentro due amici
dubbi ci aspettano fuori dalla scuola
e allora scusate ma nemo nello sport ma
se questa questa forse eravamo meno
insomma non c'è fine al regno unito non
farti prendere veramente 5 dan gilbert i
dauni sono dei mostri
roma altro ancora dietro alla scuola
dove stiamo andando
la libreria nella stai molto attento
quando salti qua non l'abbiamo visto
professione
ho visto qualcuno che ancora era ancora
vivo dai sono tenuto poche volte per il
momento è solo che queste tipo 1 è un po
più facile tritatutto vogliono
aspettarci a cuba ci sono due zombie
attento salviamo penso ma passiamo da
sotto di te che non è più facile invece
che saltare sopra bravissima non capisco
7 st brook e facendo stiamo noi vi siamo
diventati bravi ce l'abbiamo fatta e
andare sul bambino fu quella roba verde
e sarà tipo lo slime zombie mondo piano
questo è quello che ti piacciono a te
stare in equilibrio da è stato facile
fino adesso vedo il bene a ioni davvero
[Musica]
abbiamo prima di invitare eccomi
prendiamo il medaglione anch'io l'ho
preso
il rito che siamo riusciti a scappare
così vero severi e scendiamo in altre
stelle
io sceglierei questo avvolgerà la pizza
e andiamo dopo la pizza da dove siamo
finiti
quando se la pizza gigante un ristorante
ma stare sui cortei vidal e sta già
andando per lasciarsi tutta l'abilità
certo schifo riesce a superarli andare a
velocissimo ma non porti arrostire no
aver preso la forchetta ho capito cos'è
questo schifo rumo vogliono mandarci
arricchirci è tutta mia vicina ma
difficile quella di prima era molto più
facile sono caduto anch'io vi liberate
questa musica prima la usava sempre nei
video di anni fa no veramente sto o di
autobotte forchette difficilissimo per
un altro anno ancora ferma le forche
davvero
non ci credi separato tutto arrivando
dai dai che sta sfruttando quindi credo
che sta esaltando non mancano posti per
salvare lì dove sono io
quindi fronte a te salta attenta bravo
pure abbiamo dentro uno no per ora sulla
four che siamo tutti a non cadere
versione è la dovevi petto porta al bar
ma vediamo qua dopo dopo queste bibite
dopo il ghiaccio ok dai ci siamo fatti
ci siamo quasi
si è salvato allora io vado con la
forchetta centrale giusto
prendiamo su questa vitale si sta e
critica
[Musica]
ecco evitare che sta andando a mangiare
già andando a testare se inseriamo qui
partì aspetta però all'inizio non ce la
faccio sempre parlato arrivando il
ragazzo che sta mangiando la pizza
gigliata è la pressione che entreremo
nella sua bocca di magra stata lei a
giocare ad entrare non ho appreso che
curava crostata per la bottiglia voto
betitaly sono spesso di la caletta dove
di cosenza per salvare è infatti lo
cerca di non mappa dove devo andare
nel cestino di salvare no vabbè si
vogliono mangiare le formiche giganti
attento peperoncino ci mangiano portiamo
dentro al cestino del tir mix questione
date le formiche siamo riusciti
wow dobbiamo salire sopra e attento le
formiche timore o no si è così 4 mi sono
messo a fare il cestino
l'assoluta abbiamo subito stiamo sui
panini dai ci siamo quasi ci siamo
questo quanto lo stato paghi gialla sono
stata sì sì l'ho già superiore della
linea salvare qui siamo quasi arrivati
alla pizza
ci stiamo avvicinando al ragazzo che non
sono mai forse come il ragazzo mangione
avete visto l'episodio tedeschi premi
del ragazzo mangione che ci ha mangiato
perché faceva troppo ridere
lei è stato sugli ingredienti e vediamo
[Musica]
sono sfracellato tra il pomodoro e
formaggio e giusti tramontata
ecco la vita restano pronti a salire
nella bocca la pizza qualcosa di stare
nelle botti la creazione di caffè
perfezionano piccola grande tutti le la
come si chiama google
vediamo che cosa ha mancato di laser
[Risate]
[Musica]
ma cosa si è mangiato una chitarra in
terra mia chitarra sembra alle corde di
una chitarra
siamo qui tutti siamo al centro a quello
centro chiama rimasti siamo arrivati al
punto proibito
in italia non mi sono ancora sfracellata
dai bui farcela no penso che stiamo in
bagno perché in genere sparati nel
caminetto
io non avevo nemmeno via spicci volare
[Musica]
siamo qua nelle fogne aiuta forse ce
l'abbiamo fatta
[Musica]
purtroppo vidal è rimasto bloccato e
rimasto bloccato niente riesco andare
avanti devo dire
le tv spenta la macchina non è difficile
quindi che stava supercorsa farcela 76
quasi attento l'ho battuto
rubra
[Applauso]
oggi abbiamo collezionato due medaglioni
salviamo e completa per evitare che è
rimasta di notte a 3 pari a state un bel
feeling che proporrà mila sono quattro
cartellini di pubblicare per vedere
inoltre altri video anche su quello che
preferite
buona visione ciao